[Music]
lately all her co-workers are getting
pregnant it seems like she's very upset
why can't i get pregnant i just don't
know how
to support her like emotionally going
through all this in those moments what
i've learned to do is to shut my mouth
and listen and not try to solve a thing
[Music]
welcome to the no spin zone this is the
doctor john i don't think this whole
show is suspenseful
it's like a
washing machine in here this is the dr
john deloney show i'm so glad you're
joining us talking about mental health
relationships marriage and parenting
uh
on
the best podcast ever really uh on all
those topics
um and architecture we talk about i
actually don't talk about architecture
at all i just thought i'd throw that in
there it sounds good uh art vandelay
import export be great hey we're glad
that you're with us if you want to be on
the show give us a buzz at one eight
four four six nine three thirty two
ninety one it's one eight four four six
nine three three two nine one
or go to johndaloni.com
ask a s k and i just have to say dude
i'm looking in the booth right now jenna
is straight up
rocking
overalls just boys to men's style looks
fantastic ben just got off the plane
from hawaii looking fantastic and kelly
is rocking her texas gas station shirt
go buckys we love buckies and we all
love some beaver nuggets
yes
i had some actually because my husband
went for the first time
and he was like have you ever heard of
bucky's like really seriously and so he
was he's got these things called beaver
nuggets he was so excited it's like
diabetes in a bag
yeah they're so good
and
a bucky's just opened up in tennessee
and it's like a landmark here anyway we
that's that's what the world's come to
good folks is we
really celebrate the opening of a
gigantic gas station slash
planet system whatever all right let's
go to morgan in st louis what's up
morgan save us hey hey hey i'm still
giggling about diabetes in a bag
what's happening
uh hi thanks for having me on the uh the
greatest architecture podcast ever yes
so tell us about your architecture
challenges and um if you have some some
drainage issues or some roofing i don't
know
you know it's actually it's a decent
segway because i'm looking for some
guidance uh navigating living situations
post divorce okay cool
yeah um hey you should work in radio
that was a fantastic transition from a
from a train wreck to an actual segment
yeah i'm not sure i'm cut out for that
um so my my now ex-husband we separated
last october um we
our divorce was final in march
um and we have three little boys they
are now 10 9 and 6. holy smokes um
yeah so when when we divorced or even
when we separated we had two homes on
the property where we lived so he moved
into the old house i stayed in the house
we had remodeled
with the kiddos and
committed to staying here for 18 months
to kind of give the kids a transition
my folks joke that it's divorce site
because they see both of us every day
um they run back and forth um you know
if it's we're gonna leave to school and
one of the boys says hey can i go
say hi to dad yes you can run on over so
it's been a good transition i believe
for our kids
but it's not forever
and the moves that i'm contemplating
moving off of the property he's going to
stay on the property he has a business
that he runs on the property so that
that's what makes sense but i don't see
us living 200 yards apart as viable
indefinitely
so i'm trying to evaluate kind of what's
next and i could choose to stay local
and
keep the kids in the same school live in
the same community
i have a lot of reasons to not want to
do that
i
personally would prefer to move out of
state
with the kids and
the the reasons that i have for that
i'll also revolve around them
my career
it materially matters i've been the sole
provider for our family for the last
four years as he's doing this start-up
and
with really the dynamic that kind of
that probably destroyed our marriage and
kind of persists is that i he he views
himself as peripheral to
the family um
he's focused on providing he works all
the time
and
i just came back from vacation with the
kids um but we've vacationed alone for
the last like the children and i um for
the last
seven or eight years
um so
he's been working around the clock but
not earning anything he's just been busy
correct correct and i think
i i have a lot of compassion for that i
don't think he's trying to
um
i don't think there's some
bad motivation i i think he's fear
driven he's he's terrified to fail and
so he just keeps pouring and pouring and
pouring himself into
into his job and it's agriculture so
it's super demanding around the clock it
is hard to get away
but when we were navigating our divorce
that was the one thing that i told him
was look like we moved to this area
we've lived here four years
we moved here to be close to your family
we lived in texas for 11 years because
that was important for his family and
his career
we moved here to be close to his family
and for his career and i don't want to
be here until the kids are all graduated
from high school i'd like to move to be
closer to my family and a support
network for me
and he agreed he said yes so that's in
the decree
it is written in a decree that i have
the right to move out of state with our
kiddos and that he intends to follow
okay um
he's not intending to anymore is he
exactly
exactly and
and now you're the bad guy
um well i that's and that's obviously
like that will that will be the outcome
kind of no matter what happens
um
he has not said like i can't leave he
hasn't pushed back on that and said how
dare you he said well hey you know you
can go but i probably can't follow right
away or what is our custody agreement
going to look like if i can't move
and um
so i guess my question is
do my kids need their dad in their lives
to like should i stay and keep pulling
my hair out juggling doing this dance
or is that just facilitating him being
an absentee
parent more or less and not being a
partner and raising them and do i
need to just say this is what he agreed
to and move on
and allow him to fail by not following
like what's best for my kids
this is hard um i
to answer that question with any sort of
certainty
i would want to spend a long time with
you and with him um let me talk around
it a little bit is that okay
yeah um
you said he's a person who's
probably deep down a good guy he's just
scared to fail
and
he's scared to fail so he's so scared to
fail that his marriage has failed his
business has failed
and now he's moved to a new place and
this business has failed and he just
hasn't called it yet um
so
he's made a lot of choices that um
revolved around him and his needs
and your kids your sons have got a
picture of what a dad is
what a husband is what a man is
and at this point i don't again
without talking to him seeing him
the external metrics are a pretty
uh dismal picture of what responsibility
looks like what character and integrity
looks like and character like
is what eric thomas says it's simply
saying you're going to do what you're
what you said you're going to do and he
hasn't done that
i would challenge you you have not had a
transition
in those boys minds y'all are not
divorced you're just living in other
rooms
they have not experienced the weight of
this transition yet
and um i um let me roll back a little
bit what ultimately led to the divorce
did somebody cheat on somebody oh did
you just have a nut like this just
sounds like you moved to the other room
it just happens that y'all got lucky and
there was two
properties i mean two houses on on the
property
what
led
it was um there was no one else it was
more or less me
um
i i accommodated i enabled this dynamic
for years and it was me ultimately
saying this is too much
that you're not here i want you here
starting to actually articulate my needs
and
running up against the wall for
several years and ultimately
giving an ultimatum saying
i'm not going to continue like this
either we want the same things and
you're going to engage you're going to
start to see a therapist you're going to
start to find some some help to
be the kind of dad you're telling me you
want to be be the kind of husband you're
telling me you want to be or you're
going to say no that's not that's not
really what i'm in this for and we're
going to go our separate ways because
i'm not i'm not going to do this anymore
so
there's a there's a insidious form of
manipulation he he left you a long time
ago
yes he left you a long time ago
and he didn't leave
which makes it worse because then it
makes you feel crazy
is that fair accurate
and then
it's it's in counseling
there's a million different definitions
here but it's the one down position
he's controlling everything from the woe
is me place we have to go move here
because i have to do this thing for you
what it's for you it's for them
and
then you are left looking at the
electric bill saying somebody has to pay
this
and i can't go on vacations with y'all
because i'm doing this for y'all
you all just go without me and it's fine
all right and so it's just one down move
and it's a control mechanism
it's it's a um
all even has it's a cowardly control
mechanism it's it's pulling the boat
from under the water instead of having
the courage to sit up and say i want to
drive this way right and then you're
forced everyone in the boat
knows you're pulling it under the water
and they don't want to go this direction
but they
they have to cut the rope and then
you're waving in the water going what
happened what happened you know what i
mean so
this this i agree to everything in the
divorce decree
and then i'm gonna leave fine cool we're
gonna do what we said we're gonna do and
i'm gonna move out of state to where i
can get some support that i haven't had
in five years ten years fifteen years
oh well i i i can't it's a it's the same
manipulation move it's the same one down
move would you just go ahead without me
and whenever i can get done doing all
this work for you and the kids and then
i'll i'll see if i can squeeze in some
you see what i'm saying it's a move it's
a move
um when you ask the question
do their boys need their dad the answer
is unequivocally yes
and
do the boys need a model
of a man who leaves his wife high and
dry abandons them and her to the tune of
some job
pick lawyer farmer
architect whatever
is that a good representation no and
what those boys are going to do if they
haven't already is they are going to
spend their life trying to figure out
what it was about that tractor that was
more important than they were
and they're going to do things like you
just mentioned we need to go say hi to
dad he likes it when we because they're
trying to solve that relationship
problem
and you're going to take him out of
state and you're going to get some peace
in your life for the first time
and he's going to begin to say things
like well your mom took took you away
from me
and just be prepared the moment this
divorce happened you're now playing a
20-year game you are planting seeds for
the relationship with your 30 and 29 and
26 year old son
not your 14 and 13 year old sons okay
because they're gonna hate you
they're gonna be pissed let me rephrase
that they're not gonna hate you they're
gonna love you deeply
they're gonna say the words i hate you
they're gonna be frustrated they're
going to be uh what about right
that's part of this transition
and you're going to have to go ahead
i can hear
him saying like in my mind because it's
a refrain of things i've heard for the
last decade well i really want to i
really wish i could but i have to work
but it's you know xyz insert excuse here
that's right and i know that that's how
the move is going to go
is well i really wish i could be there
for such and such kiddos but your mom
moved you to you know wherever and it's
it's just too hard for me to get there
and there's going to be a victim card
that's right and the kids are going to
be mad at me and like
ultimately i hope they don't land there
indefinitely i hope they mature through
that and it gives them perspective to
see the dynamic for what it is but
that's why i'm i need to be confident in
whatever decision i make
to kind of navigate those waters for
myself so
let me reframe two things number one
you you hear you've heard me say this
all the time don't ever we're never
gonna talk negative we're never gonna
piss on on some kid's dad or mom right
so we're not gonna never talk negatively
about that and i think that's a fair
conversation to have with him
it is fair to say
um yeah i thought your dad was gonna
come and move to the same city or the
same town and for now he's choosing to
stay here
that's not a mean statement that's not a
dishonest statement that's a very fair
honest statement
okay
and
it would also be fair for him to tell
them
uh mom yeah me and mom agreed that um we
were gonna leave and she's choosing to
leave sooner uh she's choosing to leave
now and i'm choosing to stay but the
truth is he's choosing to stay in in not
in violation but counter to the
agreement y'all made right and he's he's
a girl man he's allowed to do that the
second thing i want to reframe is this
you've already made the decision
you divorced him
he left you you divorced them
the longer you hang on and pretend you
haven't made that decision
the more chaos intention and anxiety
those kids are going to absorb
it sounds like you haven't come to terms
with you divorced him
you know
i think what i haven't come to terms
with is
to your point
what the divorce really means for my
kids
for me personally i feel a million times
more at peace i feel like our home is
more peaceful i feel like life
there's
i
personally feel very comfortable in
you're playing both sides of the fence
because you know if you're if something
happens he's going to come over and help
he's right there
but i don't want him
here like you sound like you
are
ready to jump
are you ready to go i know the i know
the questions about the boys are all
well and good but they can't be used as
a proxy for your fear too are you scared
to go
no 100 i'm not and go and
initially initially some of that was
true like pipes froze well you know i
called him hey can you help me with this
but
that's been
that was the first couple months
um i've
i'm not leaning there at all at this
point very cool then now you just gotta
now you gotta
i'm gonna load the truck
yeah
and yes this this there is not a way in
the answer there's not a way to do this
without a lot of tears and a lot of
heartbreak and a lot of second guessing
and just because something hurts and
feels very painful doesn't mean it's not
the right decision
agreed
in a perfect world when you sat down
with him your husband and said
i'm tired of you
having an affair with your imaginary
jobs
and i'm tired of being a single mom
raising three young little boys
and i'm tired of having to explain to
three little boys why their daddy is
cheating on their family with a tractor
and i need these things from you and he
looked at you and said
um
i hear you and i'm all in
and so you let your needs be heard
and he said i prefer to divorce you
and so you're carrying a lot of guilt
and a lot of shame and you got to set
that stuff down and be about living your
life
this feels like a again
i feel much more confident my answer if
we were sitting down the three of us me
and you and your husband
but this feels like another move
and it's a power move it's just not a
loud beat your chest power move it's an
all shucks woe is me power move
but it's still a move
the divorces happen the divorce is final
you can't be roommates on the same place
um or at some point he brings home
somebody else or at some point you meet
somebody else
and that you know i mean like you can't
live like this it just becomes a strange
weird arrangement
um and you need community and you need
support and if you don't have this here
in this little town then you need to go
back to your original plan and make your
plan happen and yes your boys are going
to be pissed and yes they're going to
say things like i hate you and i can't
believe you took us away from everything
we knew and loved we missed the farm but
all that stuff's going to be true
but they made also
have peace for the first time in their
entire life
and they hope
they may have um a mom who's able to
breathe for the first time in her entire
life and have that rippled through
they're always gonna wonder what they
did
um what was wrong with them
that dad wouldn't go on vacation with
them the dad was more interested in
whatever than them
they're always going to wonder why dad
picked this over mom my dad picked this
over that and they're always going to
wonder why you took him away
and hopefully
stay invested and you stay plugged in
you stay intentional even through the
storms because the storm's going to come
you stay intentional through those
things man when they're 18 19 20 25 30
they're gonna realize what a brave
powerful mom they have
and i'm sorry you're
sorry i've been through this this has
been a long time coming i'm sorry
i'm happy to walk with you through this
man um don't hesitate to call me morgan
if i can ever help all right um
best of luck we'll be right back
hey what's up delony here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.com that's betterhelphelp.com
all right let's go to joe in
clayton california hey what's up joe
hey john how are you good brother how we
doing
pretty good good deal taking my call
yeah man what's up how can i help okay
so my question is how do i support my
wife emotionally while we're going
through
her fertility treatment
so
a little back story on this about three
years ago she had a early um
uh can you think of the name right now
i'm sorry i got a little nervous no
that's all good uh miss carrick um
miscarriage yeah sorry i couldn't think
of a word
and then so we went through that you
know it's a little difficult time and
then about a year in we started seeing
some doctors because uh
we weren't having a baby and then
she did some medication
and
now you know going forward we're going
through this now
we did one iui um as part of the doctor
and that didn't work out we're still
waiting to hear back on that
but i just feel like lately
you know she's talking she works at a
hospital
so lately all her co-workers are getting
pregnant it seems like on social media
that's all she's seen
and i just feel like
that's all we've been she's been
bringing up and talking and she's very
upset why can't i get pregnant and stuff
like that
i just don't know how
to support her like emotionally going
through all this
um none of our close close friends
have any kids that have gone through
this so
i don't feel like any of them have
helped or can't help
i just don't know i feel like i'm
overwhelmed with this yeah man well
thank you so much and i can tell you
from personal experience i've done this
the wrong way on um in
in a pretty dramatic fashion so
um i'm gonna tell you things i've when
i'm sitting with i've sat with couples
to talk about this and i'll tell you
i'll mix it and match with my own
experience okay
um first
i dramatically
i missed i failed
i did not understand the scope of
devastation that a miscarriage
uh brought to my wife
a letter down
okay
so what i would tell you is however you
felt or didn't feel
multiply that by a thousand
the women i've met with over the last
decade who've experienced miscarriages
have said things like
i feel like my body's
taking is killing babies i feel like my
body doesn't work properly i feel like
i'm failing as a woman like some really
deep
powerful hard things
that are core to identity right really
tough stuff
and as a husband i was like i mean it's
just mother nature or it's just this or
it's just that completely missed it okay
right so
in those moments what i've learned to do
is to shut my mouth
and listen and not try to solve a thing
but to just be with
okay
okay the second thing is is i recommend
to every single couple going through
some sort of infertility um
having that conversation the discussions
the hey this isn't happening as fast as
we thought
to go
spend some time together
having the conversation about how far
are we going to go down this road
and what i mean by that is there is
always a doctor or a treatment facility
that will sell you any number of
different ideas or tricks or
opportunities
to the tune of
hundreds of thousands of dollars
that's right so for me and my wife when
we started we said we will not go
past line
x y and z
and for us it was we're not going to do
infertility stuff we're not going to go
through all we'll do you know basic
vitamins will do some
coach you know whatever
and it ended up working out for us but
we're not gonna go through all these
other things
okay but we drew a line in the sand and
then we had to grieve the crap out of
that line
okay and this is where a lot of um
husbands don't get it
that
for us again i'm painting a broad
general brush here right this is not
everybody this is just a big generalized
picture
i started thinking about kids
like
after i was married for a while like huh
it'd be cool to have like a little dude
like me running around like i had a
totally different picture
um
my wife had pictures of
what her home would look like in the
kids running around in her home when she
was teeny like very very young little
girl
and so the the differences in how we
grieved
was dramatic and and big
and she
owned every inch of that and it's my job
as her husband to sit in that with her
if she'll even have me she may have to
sit in that by herself sometimes
okay
and you and or her
then you walk past that empty room
and you're imagining the nursery
you're imagining a little truck
scattered all over the place
and you go to somebody's room and you
see like at your friend's house and
they've got like a stack of diapers
somewhere
right
um every period is devastating have you
experienced that
um well
at first she did when we first got
married she didn't really want kids so
that's like the thing that kind of threw
me off that i feel like it's just
recently in the past three years
i don't know if maybe because she's
getting older what so let me let me tell
you this whatever she said when y'all
first got married throw it out the
window it doesn't matter y'all are here
now okay right right and the more you
try to be like yeah but three years ago
dude we're here now you know we're here
now
um
and now she's telling you that
every time
she has a period it's that her body's
failed her again
right and something's wrong and quite
honestly there's a feeling that she's
failed you
and she's failed this picture and this
family you know all those things right
yeah and that's what i've reassured her
you know that
i'm
it's not a make or break you know she's
always saying like you know
you would have made somebody else and i
reassure her all the time like no
that's not the case
that's right but i mean that's one thing
that she always brings up
and there's also there's also like i
don't know if you ever lost like a
parent or a brother or sister or
somebody close to you but there's always
that
if i just called them they wouldn't have
gotten the car
right there's always this replaying of
things that you can't change
right right and that's just part of
grief and so you're doing the right
thing by reassuring and saying thank you
here's something that is not talked
about very often that is very fair
you have needs to
and you are allowed to say
i want to take 30 days off of talking
about babies
it's heavy in the home i feel like i'm
losing my wife and i know that you're
grieving i am too
i want to take 30 days off from the baby
conversation
it's becoming overwhelming in the house
okay and you're allowed to have that
need also
yeah i think that's that's kind of what
i was
wanting to bring up but without seeming
unsensitive or trying to say you know
i don't want a kid you know what i mean
because i feel like she might take it to
that extreme no no no what i'm saying is
there's a difference between saying you
need to shut up or you need to get over
it that's insensitive
right
um
saying i'm hurting too
and every time you come home talking
about how everybody else has babies i
have to hear it i i can't hear it either
it hurts
i need a break
from talking about this can we stop
quote unquote trying to have a kid can
we give it 60 days two months and then
we'll reset
and um
it may be a
here's another another angle to this
that i would recommend you take if you
haven't already
um i would ask that you and her
on your own alone
write a letter
to the baby that you lost
okay
did y'all name this kid
no
okay um i have tattooed on my body three
babies that we lost in miscarriage with
names okay
and i had to grieve them my wife grieved
them we grieved them together
as though we lost a child that we we're
holding okay
it's a part of the grief
it's part of the grief cycle and
women are often told yeah it's cool man
we'll just try again
oh that sucks you know what i mean and
so they're what they're encouraged by
their community is to bury that grief
shove it down
just a miscarriage get over yourself
and so uh i'd recommend having some sort
of
small ceremony with just you too
okay okay and it's gonna be heavy it's
gonna be hard and it's gonna be
liberating
okay can i definitely try that um if you
bring that up
and say this is something you wanna do
and you'd love her to join you that is a
totally different thing than telling her
hey i think you're probably going
through some grief and so probably help
if you did you see what i'm saying i
want you to take ownership of this okay
okay right okay ownership of i want to
take 60 days off in in the house i need
this for me because i'm hurting too i
see i i hurt when my wife hurts
let's take 60 days off from talking
about babies let's take 30 days off
whatever that looks like let's stop
trying we need to keep having sex right
we still do the fun part but we're going
to stop quote-unquote trying to have
babies and following the clock and oh
it's three o'clock let's you know all
that kind of we're gonna stop that for
60 days
i need to get back to just being with my
wife
yeah and i think that's that's where i
feel like i'm getting overwhelmed with
that too because i work a ton of hours
i usually get home i wake up about two
in the morning and get home about 5 30
when it's just like you said it's that
we got to do we gotta do this we gotta
do this and it seems like it's
like a second job yeah yeah yeah and
yes and at first you're like you can't
tell your buddies that because it's like
oh oh when when you mean every day at
five o'clock you have to have sex
yeah but it comes with a lot of pressure
and a lot of expectation a lot of
you get taken out of it right you become
a vessel for this
other picture right right and it's not
it's not something about can it's not
connection it's not something about you
know
people aren't even having fun anymore
it's about
a very clinical op like and it's just
yeah everybody said pause control delete
let's reset right right okay yeah
um but again hear me say real clearly
this is about you saying here's what i
need not here's what you should
do okay okay it may even help if you
write down
here's what i need and why because i'm
hurting i'm scared i'm sad
and by the way
it's not um
if she's saying you should have just
married somebody else i
i
if you're sad that you don't that she's
not pregnant that you haven't had a kid
yet it's okay to say that out loud
hiding from her or keeping that secret
from her is not helping your marriage
right yeah okay
and so be honest with her when you have
that um small little ceremony for that
baby
that she's still grieving even though
she thinks she's not she's still
grieving that thing uh or that little
that little boy girl whatever you guys
decide um
in that letter
say i'm gonna miss you
i'm gonna miss you i had some when she
told me we were pregnant i remember the
day she told me i remember how she told
me i got kind of scared and i got
freaked out and i looked at our bank
account
and also got pretty excited
take some kid you know the dodgers game
or whatever and watch the dodgers get
beat by the astros because astros are
superior
uh
and uh
especially when they got trash cans on
the side right all those things right
all those things yeah
um and hey can i just tell you i'm sorry
thank you i've been there and i'm sorry
i'm sorry that your marriage is a mess
i'm sorry that your wife is hurting
sorry about miscarriage
sorry about there's just not a path
forward right now because we thought
we're gonna be here and now we're not we
don't know what's next i'm sorry about
all that stuff in there dude
yeah it's definitely uh something that i
did not
i didn't think it was gonna be this
difficult you know i just when you think
about babies you think it's how it's
done and it's easy and
i did not think it was gonna be this
difficult so it's definitely a little
and you dude your wife will see every 16
year old that accidentally got pregnant
and be like are you freaking kidding me
you know what i mean yeah trust me yeah
she'll she'll point out every accidental
pregnancy she'll point out every
you know [ __ ] at work that's just
getting yeah so-and-so got knocked off
it's so right it's it's a reminder to
her that she has failed and the path
through that
she clearly she hasn't failed anything
but the path through that is grief
okay right it's grief we had a picture
of what things were going to be and that
picture's not happening yet it might and
we need to come up with a very
um very strong thick black line as a
finish line for how far we're going to
go
before we start that point um otherwise
you're gonna find yourself 200 000 in
debt with 40 fertilized embryos and you
don't know what what to do next
right right
so make a plan um and
spend some time grieving with her
these are your needs not hers and do not
try to fix her man just be with her this
is a hard hard season
hey
and if you do get pregnant in the next
two months three months six months nine
months please let me know and we will
celebrate you man i'll be high-fiving
you and if you don't get pregnant i'll
celebrate you too
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless homebuyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process
you need folks like my friends at
churchill mortgage churchill is a ramsey
trusted provider that's been helping
people with their home mortgages for
decades and their home buyer edge
program will help you skip a bunch of
the stress here's how it works apply to
become a churchill certified home buyer
and cap your interest rate for 90 days
then you'll get a 5 000 seller guarantee
to help your offer stand out so go ahead
take a deep breath because churchill has
your back check them out at
churchillmortgage.com
deloney and get the homebuyer edge today
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's take one
more let's go to laurie in oh claire
wisconsin what's up lori
hey hey dr john i feel like we're old
friends i've never missed a show and
this week i listened to your 300th
episode so congratulations on that i
thank you for that i appreciate that i i
i am first in line to think we were not
going to make it that far
having fun thank you for thank you for
riding in our gang man i'm really
grateful yeah
so what's up
so today i just have a question about
guilt
so last september my uncle died
unexpectedly and i was appointed the
executor of the estate
he lived in new orleans i live in
wisconsin and my brother at the time
lived in alaska
and i was starting a new job at the end
of september and time wasn't really
something we had much of
so my brother flew from alaska to st
louis and i flew to st louis to his
brother-in-law's house and then we drove
to new orleans where i rented a u-haul
uh just to take back you know a few
things from my uncle's house so when we
got there
you know we just
tore through the place like a tornado
and what we were basically looking for
were you know important documents you
know the deed to the house were there
any tax forms his wallet is checkbook
bills you know any financial documents
and
i just feel very guilty that we went
into this man's house just went through
everything you know obviously we
couldn't keep much
and i just feel really bad that we seem
to just
throw this man's life away
and this was right after hurricane ida
had came through though fema was still
picking up all these you know
garbage at the end of the curb but
basically we ended up throwing out
most of this man's possessions we did
work with the local church agency where
we donated a bunch of stuff but you know
he was a police officer most of his life
and he had you know certificates and
awards and plaques and badges
and you know we just we couldn't keep
all that and we threw it all away
so fast forward to this year where i am
now and my dad is on hospice
he's probably not going to see september
and i'm going to be in the same boat
obviously well my brother and i will
have more time he does live back home
now
um
but this is the home that i grew up in
as a child and how do i
just go through that home and just get
rid of everything yeah
number one i'm so sorry
thank you
uh you must be somebody special for both
of these men these important men in your
life to appoint you as the person to
see through things
right pretty cool and come on man could
they pick somebody else right it's both
in
oh
um
so guilt is guilt is good let's don't
try to avoid guilt okay i don't think
guilt is the challenge here
the challenge here is um do you have a
good relationship with your uncle do you
like him
oh yes he was my best friend and you
know it just
was so unexpected that was quite a shock
yeah
um i'm thinking of my uncles
and i've got several of them and they
all have very particular
ways they draft
and i got some really centralized uncles
and some straightforward uncles i got
one uncle that smells a little bit like
leather
cowboy
got an uncle that's a tech guy kind of
smells like an iphone i guess i don't
know what this smells like google i
guess
um
here's what i'm getting at
it was about a year ago i was cleaning
out some things in my closet and i found
a jacket like a like a sports coat of
that my granddad used to wear my
granddad died
the greatest men i've ever known
greatest man i've ever met
and i kept that jacket it didn't fit i
always had dreams of it fitting and then
getting it fixed and tailored and it has
i've carried it around for a long long
time and he actually gave it to me
before he died so i've been carrying it
for years
and i was getting rid of clothes and i
put it back on the rack and then i took
it off and here's the words i said to
myself my granddad is not in this jacket
and i put my hand on my chest and i said
my granddad's right here
and your uncle's not in those
certificates and those badges and he
would have told you throw all that crap
away you know what i mean
and yet
there's something that tells us no uncle
uncle whoever is in that stuff and he's
not he's with you
and then with your dad very very similar
can your dad still hear you and
understand you
oh yeah yep
have you written him the letter and read
it to him yet
no you need to do that asap
okay
what he means to you
what he um
what you're gonna take from what he gave
you
and how you're gonna communicate that on
um
how his life meant something
and then what you will have is one of
the most precious moments a person can
have on planet earth which is the moment
to consciously and directly and with
love say goodbye
with purpose and meaning and dignity
and
then you're gonna have to tell yourself
he's not in that stuff
i would also challenge you to tell your
place where you work if it at all
possible dude i need a week off because
my dad died
and god help them if they don't give you
a week off good grief
or two weeks for crying out loud
right
um i've known people that
turn objects into people
and that's a life of misery
[Music]
okay
yep and all the things i'm saying are
not easy
none of this is easy
are there a couple of sentimental things
about that that you remember from your
dad
oh yeah he was into model trains so you
know he's got all this
model train sets and stuff and my
brother nor i are interested in that
right um don't throw those out there's
some wackadoos who want to buy some
trains man you want to sell those
they'll pay for your retirement but
but maybe grab one that you love that
you remember
yeah i had a ceramic i don't know why i
had a ceramic
my wife my grandmother collected ceramic
birds
and every time i walked in the house she
reminded me you're not allowed to touch
those
this is gonna shock you lori but i was a
bit destructive as a child that was just
chaotic and like a ball of energy
luckily luckily i've grown up and i've
become uh very still and on time and
uh
right whatever
um
and when she died right before she died
she said like anything you need want
from here
and i was like i need that ceramic blue
jay in the ceramic cardinal
and that's what i got i got those two
things
and she's not in those things she's in
my heart she's she's in
my raising of my kids but i keep those
two things and whenever i see a cardinal
out when i'm hunting out in the woods or
something i see a cardinal and i just
smile
right it's so when my dad passes away
there's two or three things i've already
told my brother and sister i i get these
three things
and
anything else then we whatever just give
it away but there's a couple of things
that are gonna mean a lot to me that
just remind me of my old man right he's
not in them but they remind me so maybe
think of a couple of things and say
these are gonna be mine a pocketknife
and a badge and a train right something
like that
and then everything else man he's just
not in that stuff
that's true yes
but i sure think this is way more
related to the loss
the sudden loss and the pending loss
than it is about the guilt over the
homes i think guilt is probably
misplaced grief
yeah i think you're right now that
you've explained it that way
your life will be really rich if you
write that letter and read it to him
yeah you're absolutely right i need to
get working on that
today
today yes
lori okay
um after he passes
yep um
you don't have to but i welcome
if you uh wanna
send me a draft of the letter i'll read
it over the air so people can know how
great your dad was
that would be wonderful cool to honor
him like that and you could tell him
there's this podcast that like 13 people
listen to dad
we're gonna we're gonna blow you up on
it
you're gonna be famous dad you're gonna
be famous
and he's gonna say i i heard that
podcast i probably don't want to be on
that one
can you get me on joe rogan's podcast
it's way bigger
[Laughter]
fantastic hey can i tell you this
sure
man
i ca i can't tell you as the dad of a
six-year-old little girl
i hope my baby girl loves me in my final
days as much as you love your old man
she will he's a lucky ah
i'm kind of a mess
but your dad man
god almighty what a lucky lucky man
what a lucky man to have lori as as his
eldest as a daughter incredible
thank you so much for calling uh let us
know how that um reading him that letter
goes
and if any way possible read it in
person it's worth the plane ticket
uh maybe if you don't have the money
it's worth the plane ticket go down
there and make sure you see him in
person
then think of a couple things and then
get on out of there he's not in those
things and everybody listening
people aren't in stuff peop your worth
is not in the certificates you're worth
not in the trophies you're worth nothing
little plaques
your worth is in the lives you changed
your worth is in the hearts you filled
up
your worth is
in your spiritual life and your worth is
innate
you have worth we'll be right back
hey delony here one of the things i love
about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloni.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
kelly why did you hear me this song
in the first call you made a comment
about the guy having an affair with a
tractor
and immediately my mind went to this
song so enjoy
oh and that's okay so
[Music]
right above her harry styles tattoo um
on her upper shoulder she does have a
kenny chesney tattoo
now i get it kelly
today's song of the day is kenny
chesney's she thinks my tractor is sexy
and it goes like this
plowing these fields in the hot summer
sun over by the gate lordy here she
comes with a basket full of chicken and
a big cold jug of sweet tea i make a
little room and she climbs on up
open up the throttle and stir little
dust just see her look just look at her
face she ain't fooling me
she thinks my tractor is sexy is this a
song
come on country singers we can do better
than this
she's always staring at me while i'm
i can't even good to see you we'll see
y'all soon attractors sexy